Chúng ta sẽ trung nghe 2 bây bài tháng bài, đôi tuần cầu mấy nữ Việt Nam đã dành trước
cô định nội dung bốn người tại dài vô định cầu mấy thế giới 2 ngày 2020.
Dính giả ở thai lăn, sau khi lỗi nụ sọng đánh bại đổi chủ nhà thế lăn 2 một trong trận Trung két
kịch tính.
Bí giả trước hôm 1, tì số 1 ngày 2 ngày 5 ử vãn đầu, các học cho của hưởng viên trình
thiếp vui đã thi đầu kinh cường, dành lại thiê trận với chiến tháng 12, 2.
Văn cứ định chim kiến sự tỏa sáng của bộ tư trình thiện ngọt ý,
nguyễn thiện, nguyễn thiện ngọt huyên, giúp tình Việt Nam dành trên tháng 8 đà 15,
bài và khép lại trận đấu với tí số 2 một.
Chính tháng 9, khóc chi giúp đổi tình nữ Việt Nam vục thu trận thu loại nội dung bàn
người trước đó một ngày.
Mà còn đang dấu lần thứ 8 lên nội vô định thế giới ở nội dung bốn người,
sau các năm 2020, 2 ngày 2020, 2 ngày 2020.
Tưởng dành vi chương bàn ảy sia tình người chiến, 5 ngày 2020,
a quân dài vô định thế giới 2020, 2 ngày 2020 và vô định của các cầu 12, 2020,
1 ngày 2020.
Đội tình cầu 12,5 đăng cho thấy sự vơn lên mạnh mẽ,
từng bước tù hẹp khoảng cách và phá thế được tôn lâu này của thế lan Ấn môn thế thào này.